[Music]
ilya is with us i'm gonna try and mess
that up in chicago is it ilya
yes sir you got it right thank you thank
you it took me about three tries how can
i help um yeah so i have a question
basically kind of of uh what you guys
would do in my situation
um i just got a brand new job literally
starting second week right now good for
you my wife
thank you my wife and i um have two cars
a 2011 camry with a 123 000 miles that
we own outright and a 2020 rashford that
we currently lease it's a three year
lease we're halfway through it right now
um and with this new job i get a company
car oh um
i'm just trying to figure out that i can
use for personal use as well so i'm just
trying to figure out like what is the
best course of action i know the car
market is crazy right now so i can
probably sell the camry for the most i
can like ever get for it
um
and
if i can i don't even know if it's
possible to get out of the lease like
how do i go about that and is that even
possible every money
yes
liquid
cash we have about 25
okay good
well you can just pay off the the rev
uh you're buying the lease out early and
you're you know at the end of the lease
closed in least there's a buyout amount
right
yeah amount you can buy the car for it's
that plus some of your lease payment
is what it'll be you can call them for
an early buyout number which is like a
payoff on a loan
okay yeah that's gonna and you've got
enough you've got enough money to pay it
off
okay pay you getting how much other debt
have you got
so yeah that's the thing we have about
uh 15 000 in student loans that
the reason we haven't paid it off yet is
because we just got married in december
and i
was like in the job market and i finally
got this job and we were waiting until i
like started and
now we're trying to get everything
aligned now cool
okay well i wouldn't sell the camry
because it's not gonna free up a payment
and then you're gonna have to turn
around and go get another car on top of
that but i like getting rid of the lease
well they got a company car though they
only need one car oh you only need one
car for the whole family he's got he's
got a company car and then either keep
the rev or keep the camry yeah so i was
going to say keep the rav and pay it off
yeah and then sell the camry yeah sell
the camry and and then let's throw the
rest over the student loan yeah so you
got 25 and uh
uh you said you're three years in
i don't know what they're halfway what's
that rav4 worth you think
oh man i don't even know i'm a pretty
penny in today's market that's for sure
how many of them i was asking
how many people paid 300 a month for the
rat right now
all right
let let's pretend okay i'll just make up
a number let's say 15 000 buys at lease
out i'm probably not that far off okay
you with me okay so now you own the ref
and you got thousand dollars in the bank
and you sell the camry for five you got
15 000 in the bank oh now we're gonna
pay off the student loan wait we're
broke yeah it's a good idea cause you
were already broke now we just admitted
it and now you're gonna use a new job to
build up your emergency fund and you're
100 debt free am i right
yep so that's the kind of game plan i
want to execute here if i can
i don't know if you're going i don't
know what the payoff is on that rev
but uh i what i would do is pay off the
rav sell the camry pay all of it towards
the student loan but a thousand dollars
and you're on baby step two working on
your student loan what's the new job pay
uh
like household income for both of us
base is about 115
and not including side hustles and like
commission
bonuses we're about like 130 140. so at
the latest by halloween you're 100 debt
free
okay
you see how we're doing this okay
yeah absolutely no screwing around and i
don't want to hear about going on some
vacation while you've got a student loan
staring you in the face
yes sir you just went to work so by god
go to work
yes sir i hear you
that rav4 is worth about 35 40 grand by
the way okay all right but yeah that's a
lot of pretty pennies yeah so um i
wonder if
i i don't did he tell us tonight he gave
you the year
it was 2020. okay
so it's pretty new
it's not gonna be a 15 payoff then it's
gonna be a 20
20 22 somewhere in there probably to buy
that lease out so he's halfway through a
three year lease
yeah so um
the buyout and the lease had to do with
old used car numbers before the market
went nuts so
could sell it
um and make a profit at this point he's
not they're making enough money to clean
this mess up by halloween either way
yeah so get her get her done if you like
the rav4 keep the rav4 yeah well i mean
you like the rav4 better than a 2011
camry yeah
i think it'll run forever it's only got
120 000 miles i mean i'm not it's not a
bad hoopty but it's a hoop okay if
you're gonna choose you're taking 110
he's cleaning up his mess he doesn't
have to they don't have to because if if
they get rid of it they're driving a
hooptie you know what's gonna happen
this time next year they're buying
another car yeah for cash anyway so they
started might as well just keep the good
car and work your way through it yeah
that's the way i'm looking at but i mean
you can argue with me if you want i'm
not gonna dare do that not here we'll do
that off air why not because i can't win
dave it's not fun for me come on george
of course it's fun and of course you
could win we'll let you win sometimes
thank you but if you let me win did i
really win that's the point oh
the thing with these car leases dave a
lot of people are probably in one and
thinking should i get out how do you
know the right way to get out of a lease
is it always early but you know
and save up the cash the car lease is
the worst buy
in all of automotive
and here's why
when you put in the value of the car
and you look at what you're paying on it
your cost of capital on average and car
fleece is 14.2 percent wow so you're
borrowing money at 14 interest they
don't disclose that it's interest
because it's not technically interest
you're technically renting the car so
there's no truth in lending law because
there's not technically any lending
point being real good time to get out of
a car is now
if you can get rid of that lease by
selling that puppy in this up market
that'd be a real good plan because
you're getting fleeced in your lease